good morning and welcome to the work
session on House Bill
619 this is a work session and not a
hearing so um we will be working as a
committee however we may at times choose
to call on somebody to provide some
information from the uh from those who
are here I expect that there are far
more people watching either live or the
replay of this than that are here in
this room so
welcome House Bill 69 has a number of
different sections um the let me make
sure I'm close to the microphone um this
bill deals with both medical issues
School issues and conversion therapy so
um if we and sort of walk through this
bill the first section of medical begins
with um legislative findings on the top
of Page Three uh page one so it goes
through with legislative findings that
speak to a lot of the background
information um and continues through the
end of page suits for a system of gender
dysphoria care for minors there is uh
section
135-1 which provides
definitions that that is the top of page
four on um page page six line 7 there is
135-20 is
135-1 colon 3 which is a Prohibition on
use of public funds for gender
transition
care turning to page seven line five
135g which is
enforcement same page line 26 there is
um
135-1 insurance coverage um the first is
a mandate of no coverage the second is a
non- mandate that says that no
organization shall be required to
provide coverage then at line 33 on page
seven is when it transitions when it
moves to the second section which is the
public schools there's legislative
findings that begin there and move
towards the bottom of page eight where
there is a new subdivision in the
education laws regarding sex and gender
in public school um this they're all
within 193 colon 41 that would add three
different sections one about both
enrollment and teaching issues there's a
lot packed into that one single um
section then in Roman 2 um there's one
about um gender segregated
activities
that's on line 15 line 22 is Roman 3
which is about restroom
separation and then line 24 is where
there's the violation
section and moving to line
33 there is the the final section which
is conversion
therapy conversion
therapy when somebody is coerced to do
something against their will is just
absolutely Terri
um the problem is that our language and
our law is a little bit confusing which
is unfortunate
so my intention today is that we look
through this section by section and
figure out where there's an opportunity
for conceptual agreement and when we
know where there may be some conceptual
agreement on working towards solution
then take a break I I was thinking it'
be lunch but maybe we'll take five 10 or
15 minutes just to be able to gather our
thoughts in any materials in any areas
where we have an agreement to work
towards agree work towards an agreement
in that section we will then come back
and talk about those sections and figure
out where we can find agreement okay is
that working for you that works that
works for me yes
fantastic
um so a lot of this is there's
guidelines and there's a lot of
discussion about leaving the practice of
medicine solely to medical professionals
unfortunately sometimes in the past that
has not worked well um there was a time
when not only did doctors call some
people
undesirables they also sterilized
undesirables that was practice of
medicine but not something that should
have ever been allowed by civilized
civilization and in that situation
legislation to prohibit calling people
undesirables and to prohibit their
sterilization would have been
appropriate um there was also the issue
of lobotomies that were done routinely
to people that should never have had
them and far too loose usage of electr
Shop Therapy that actually still is in
practice for some things in a severe
treatment resistant depression that is
the 14th I believe it's around the 14th
line now and I honestly commend anybody
who goes through 14 lines of treatment
for their resistant depression because
so sometimes the medical profession has
not gotten things right um back in the
Tuskegee project they they denied
antibiotic treatment to black men who
had syphilis to see what happened in the
community and the natural history of
that that was ended in 1972 in the
United States but continued through the
90s in Costa Rica and it was that was
endorsed by the American Medical
Association at the time and it was only
apologized for to years ago so while
doctors and medical societies often get
things right there are some times when
it is appropriate to step in so the
question here is if there are some areas
where we look to guidelines we figure
out where there's already agreement and
guidelines and to say in the state of
New Hampshire we are going to set this
floor on requirements for
care um that is actually being done the
conversion therapy ban is legislation
that could be considered to interfere in
the practice of medicine and um I think
that maybe that might be the first one
that we could talk about um we there are
two organizations where I've turned to
guidelines the W paath the world um PR
practitioner Association provider World
professional association for transgender
Health yes World professional I
apologize I was getting the P section
wrong um they have a new standard of
care eight that recently came out and is
very comprehensive um there's also the
endocrine Society who has dealt with
hormones um and other endocrin and
endocrine disruptors for a very long
time so I I personally look to them
towards more of the hormone
treatment the the wac guidelines um let
me pull those up they have some
guidelines around conversion therapy and
the way that they Define it is beautiful
and Brilliant
um they
I apologize for letting that one drop
go they use language that um conversion
therapy is attempts to compel a gender
diverse person through words actions or
both to identify with or behave in
accordance with the gender associated
with the sex assigned to birth I think
that that's actually a far more El
approach than what is in our existing
language and conversion
therapy um because right now it says
that it's to seek to change an
individual's sexual orientation or
gender identity against their will um
and um including sorry change an
individual sexual orientation or gender
identity including efforts to change
behaviors or gender expressions or to
eliminate or reduce sexual or romantic
attractions or feelings towards
individuals of the same gender um it
does have a carve out for transgender
care but um I think that that actually
could be strengthened along with um The
W path guidelines which are to provide a
space for um especially children who
begin in early puberty to have the
opportunity to continue to question
their gend gender ident identity um with
the expectation that that will help them
determine if they're solidifying to a
gender identity or if their gender
identity is different than that first
one that they had looked to because w
paath w path has expanded the defin
definition of different gender diversity
they've now included Unix they've
included a lot more and I believe that
those guidelines do a good job of making
sure that it's not reinforcing a binary
between being either male or female
transgender male transgender female and
it honors more of those differences
within the whole
Spectrum yes representative Shapiro yes
yes Madam chair um so it sounds like
you're not really talking about changing
the
intent um I don't think I don't have it
I don't have it in front of me but you
are talking about changing the language
and um the language you just read from W
wath wath um did not include
um samees seex relationships or samesex
attraction so would you include that
into that definition is that yes I would
add that to the definition my intention
if we're willing to work towards better
clarifying that language um would
obviously would to me it's obvious but
would include the same sex um
considerations as well um and just look
to take some of these this language and
better clarify the conversion therapy
language is that something that you
would be willing to consider working on
you
know
yes I'd be willing to think about that I
I'd want to I'd want to pull it up and
see it myself and think through it and
also um as I'm sure you're aware that
this this effort to um ban conversion
therapy like many of the bills like this
whole bill that we're working on right
now is a product of a campaign across
the
country um and so you know
I would also like to see what the ram
think about what the ramifications are
for the people who have
um you know who have really been the
stakeholders who have fought for this in
New Hampshire and around the country but
I but I but just
offand um you're talking about a more
clear language um I'm not opposed to
that and it seems to make some sense
thank you okay so it seems that I I will
query both both of you as well but just
to give a little bit more of what I'm
expecting that process would be is right
now we decide that yes we'll talk about
this a little bit more today and then
most likely anything that we come to we
have agreement towards language we would
then put together in an amendment form
and notice that so that we could get
appropriate input from those
stakeholders especially if we do get any
agreement over any of how treatments are
to be provided um I would really want to
make sure that anybody is providing
transgender care New Hampshire today
would come and tell us if any of the
proposed language that we have conflicts
with the practice that they currently
have in the state so yes so are you
talking about taking this up with an
amendment and with um and with hearing
from stakeholders within this work group
or when it comes to the big to our
committee uh that's a good that I
believe that we can have a non-main
hearing with the with this work group we
need to i' need to check with the clerk
if we are in fact willing to work
together of exactly how that would be
noticed but I would want to make sure
that any language we have has the
opportunity for good public comment most
likely in this group because we'll be
the closest with it but we'd welcome our
other members on the committee to sit in
to see yes so personally I'd rather see
that happen within our group because um
I would be very hesitant to vote for any
changes um anything that would change
the current stat on conversion therapy
without hearing from more people who are
um who that would affect more
directly I think that then that sounds
good to do that within our work
group and um anybody else have any input
and is there anybody that's opposed to
working towards clarifying the language
um within the existing intent of
conversion therapy not micophone oh not
opposed but I'm just not completely
convinced it's necessary there's other
part parts of this bill that needs much
more work or
nixing thank you my my thought is that
if there's any place here where we can
make treatment more clear and make a
more clear path with less conflict um
that that would benefit people
especially the mental health of people
who are going through this because the
more conflict that's in the media
conversion therapy is not allowed so
it's not clarifying a treatment that
isn't going I mean what's the point of
clarifying a treatment that's already
outlawed
well the the problem we had heard about
some of the chilling impacts in a
previous hearing about conversion
therapy so I'm just trying to get before
it was Outlaw lawed
so so um we have tenative agreement to
look at some language representative
Shapiro I I would just like to be clear
for myself that that doesn't include um
for me approving the language that's in
this bill which I be completely opposed
to I I I don't I believe that we would
need to work through and basically make
it reflect the more clear language from
the W path guidelines and apply that
both to gender diversity and to um and
to sexual
orientation so that that is my so my
intention is for us to look at the
language of conversion therapy using the
more clear language provided by wath as
opposed to the language that's in the
statute in order to reduce confusion
around the existing statutes for
conversion
therapy and everybody who wants to do
that to try and clarify that language
looking to The Wack guidelines so let's
hands okay fantastic then we will work
to clarify that this is not a commitment
to supporting what comes out of that
work but it's a choice to look at moving
that
so
um assuming that we are willing to look
at any of the areas within the the um
gender care we would need to look at the
definition so I will I will wait to see
if we're going to look at those
definitions um right now do we have any
information about whether or not about
um if there is current ly um surgical
gender transitions offered to minors in
New
Hampshire not that I know of because the
age of consent is 18 years or older and
so the uh any of the procedures as far
as physical procedures uh um um have to
18 what about the case where a parent
consents still still not if I think in
the state it's if there is parental
consent but also with a medical
diagnosis that this is this is something
that needs to be done um there's very
few cases where people where young
people have uh undergone surgery there
are some because there were medical
reasons for doing them uh and uh and it
was authorized by both
um Medical Professional and the parents
that this was necessary
care and was that um related to the um
the medical treatment of the gender
issues or was that medical treatment
related to something else I know that
we've heard about breast reductions from
uh girls from from people with people
who were having back problems and so
there was a reduction um in conjunction
with that when the gender identity also
um she they desired to not have their
breasts right um I believe that um that
there had been um representative not
upam I thought you would had you spoken
to any of the providers to get feedback
about whether or not there were surgical
procedures happening in New Hampshire
for minors um I
was I had and I was expecting some
information this morning and I
remembered that the head of Dartmouth
had spoke um on the day that we had the
the hearing said that no
transgender operations of children had
happened in New Hampshire under 18
breast reduction I view as something
else because um yes it could be done
because you're transitioning but also
I've had plenty of friends that were um
for bath problems or whatever had
reduction but they were probably over 18
so
um but I think we need to get hard facts
from Dartmouth Hitchcock which is our
biggest provider because if people are
worried about 13-year-olds deciding to
change their gender I I think it's
happening um so that's that's why we
need the facts on this and I'm I'm sorry
I'm not better prepared okay um there's
also the question around the fact that
once you have a surgical procedure then
and sometimes there's a revision that's
required and then um a Cascade of
surgeries that happens it may not be
something that a child is able to
appropriately understand the
consequences of that first surgery so
that must be why very few of those if
any are ever done below 18 age of 18
representative kosman thank you madam
chair so would it be um appropriate for
us to since we need to find out if these
are happening in New Hampshire if this
is something that we are um looking into
to invite those entities to come and and
talk you know answer some questions
about that so we can find out exactly
what's happening here um yes I think
that even if we don't regardless of
where we want to go on this I think that
it's very important to get information
from the stakeholders to know whether or
not um surgical gender procedures are
happening to those under 18 in New
Hampshire I think that that would be um
I think that that would be very very
important information for policym both
now and in the
future representative Hannan just a a
side comment as we're discussing this
because I I had my transition a little
over a year ago um the cost associated
with gender surgery procedures is
outrageous the cost of my surgery was
$96,000 um to do gender procedures
nowadays um oh even in the past on W
path um uh um requires uh therapists
psychologist um letters saying that
they've been seeing a patient for at
least a year and preferably two or more
um before they will off write a letter
that authorizes surgical
procedures
um insurance
companies also require that information
before they will give an okay for them
so there are other things outside
of uh a child just a child and a parent
want to get a surgical procedure done
there's there's a financial thing that's
outrageously expensive where in the past
it had been like $20,000 and that was
that could be handled but now we're
talking $90,000 and above for simple
procedures uh so there's there's much
more that's sort of financial regulating
what's going on in this process
too that thank you for that in say
that's part part of the reason lasic is
so inexpensive is because it hasn't been
covered by insurance so I wonder I
wonder how much the uh insurance covered
inflation has hit those procedures I
know that um until 2015 they were not
covered by insurance but um under
Obamacare there was a ruling that it was
um discriminatory not to provide that
that coverage and then it's led to both
an increase in procedures and apparently
a very large increase in cost
Insight one more piece to add is
that when people are scheduling surgery
surgical procedures in this particular
area I know at least in uh in Boston
where I went um um it took me a year to
get a surgery
date and and I got uh I had interviews
with three different uh surgeons in the
process so just to make sure that I was
ready for for transition uh uh having
been who I am for 25 years uh it uh they
they said okay but they had to had to
get the approvals so so uh so yes
representative missor Siri thank you I
since you did bring up
Massachusetts um I did recently speak
with a a a young woman she's 27 now but
that right before she was 18 she said
that she literally she skipped the whole
therapy process went right to the doctor
was put on hormones within 45 minutes
and then a a few years later if not even
sooner than that again no therapy went
right to the doctor had her breast
removed and so there
was in Massachusetts I know but so that
that's I really want clarification too
from some local providers about what
what that looks like
here and and I understand the breast
reduction situation is somewhat outside
it's the genital area well and then what
her story is somewhat tragic because
because she started things at such an
early age it destroyed her internally so
she has since she's had all her
reproductive organs removed not not from
her choice um and so she's permanently
sterile and she's 27 and uh it's she's
been it's been a real challenge for her
so um and it just because she started
hormones at such an early age that it
just it she didn't go through the
puberty process so even if you looked at
her which she's I mean I welcome her to
come talk to you guys um she I she looks
like she's still 16 and she's almost 30
so she was
just her her process was definitely
subverted and she and she paid for it
with her internal reproductive organs
soorry could I clarify that so as a
consequence of the puberty blockers and
hormonal therapy um she had a
consequence of having um enough of a
issue with her reproductive system that
it needed to be surgically removed all
of it excuse me
um this is a a secondhand story not from
a medical professional um stating
consequences that that are not medically
stated by a medical professional so I'm
happy to have her come here and talk to
you I would prefer to hear from her
doctor than um so I don't you know we
can tell emotional stories that make us
for against these kinds of hearings but
I'd like to stick to the facts and I'd
like to um if we're going to look at uh
outlawing surgery that's one thing
hormonal care is another thing not
allowing language in schools is a is a
third thing so let's not mix all of them
up together each time
okay that sounds fair um I the question
then would be um
whether I guess the biggest part is
we've heard a lot that people follow
guidelines but it sounds like at least
in the state just to our South PE
doctors not following guidelines because
that treatment uh providing hormones
with uh that is not the only case that
we have heard of so it is quite possible
that doctors are not following
guidelines in other states and I've
heard similar from providers in other
states as well
um sorry representative kushman thank
you madam chair um the new
hampire gender diverse Care Coalition
has a website that has like a
comprehensive list of resources for
people seeking gender um affirming care
and they actually I know that the
guidelines you know um we just heard
that you have to be with a therapist for
a year or two and that they have to
write a letter um you know recommending
that surgery is appropriate for you um
but right at the top of this page it
says that within one to one to two
sessions these seven providers in
conquered and ones in Nashville
Portsmith a bunch of
um uh psychologists and social workers
will write those letters and it only
takes one to two um sessions so it it
look seems like it's practiced pretty
regularly that you can get the letters
of recommendation rather easily at least
in New Hampshire um at least that's what
it's saying to you know on this website
by this Coalition so um it is
worth probably making sure that those
guidelines are being followed that is
outside of the W path guidelines so
Perhaps Perhaps setting those baselines
of good clinical practice within the
laws if we have people that are if we
have providers that are advertising for
a care that is outside of the W path
guidelines uh might be an appropriate
move because um right now looking at the
relative groups the W PA seems to be
pushing forward um a lot further than
some of the other other peers so if they
advise caution I think that we would do
well to keep that caution Erica yeah
represent M uh I do thank you um for
letting me speak um I also think it's
important that yes we're talking about
New Hampshire and what's happening here
in the United States but I would hope
we're also looking around the world to
see what other countries and other
nations are doing right now and I mean
I I've been trying to do my research on
both sides of all of it and and looked
to Europe and there are several
countries in Europe right now Norway
Sweden Etc who have put an absolute
pause
on all things related to miners
transitioning but especially surgery um
and you know I could walk you through
all the information that I found um you
know even in France and everything I'm
reading it right here um NHS
also they
um yeah they they just kind of put a
pause on all of it because of the real
St statistics that are starting to come
out um on how it's been affecting minors
so representative Canon um I hear you um
but I've also heard uh contradictory um
information
uh because some of the studies that were
used are out of date and aren't with
current current information so but I
think I feel that that's somewhat out of
the boundary here because we're we're
looking at at New Hampshire uh and
considering this and I guess what I want
part one of the things I do want to put
on the table is I think um that we may
be delving into too much detail that is
really a medical care information that
and should be handled by the medical
Statute because it will change as we as
people learn more about this and as as
do all things in the medical profession
as new treatments and so forth come out
so if we put things in in statute that
um uh impact the a medical the medical
organization to taking appropriate
action because we've put something in
place uh that may be the wrong thing to
do so but I I just want to flag that as
a potential issue okay uh thank you and
also the it's also possible to change
those laws if we do put them into place
as those clinical data and evidence
comes available um my question now would
then be about surgical um gender
transition procedures and given that uh
the guidelines say that you should spend
time with full hormonal treatment living
um as as your preferred gender
um and that prior to initiation of those
hormones there's also a multi-year
process uh in order to make sure that
that process is not short circuited and
that we are not providing um providing
we're not allowing surgeries to happen
that then will remove people's genitals
and reproductive organs in miners um
would we agree to work towards language
where genital where surgeries re
assignment surgeries and those under 18
Hampshire
yes um so I'm reading a letter that we
got um when they came to testify in
March and so
um occasionally babies are born um with
IND intersects or indistinguishable so
as long as there was some kind of a
clause that would allow families to deal
with however that gets treated I'm not
an expert on that by any means
um I I kind of agree that um transgender
surgery before 18 is inappropriate so
thank you um if you look on page six
under the
135-20 um it's specifically allows um
interx or a failure of a treatment
performed elsewhere even failure of um
an illegal treatment to be dealt with
page
six um starting at line 12 is where it
says what's not prohibited so 15 it says
it services to persons born with a
medically verifiable disorder of sex
development including a person with
external biological sex characteristics
that are ambiguous um and so then it has
some of the chromosomal anales and those
having both a very inter testicular
tissue um then Services provided when a
physician is out wise diagnosed a
disorder of sexual development that the
physician is determined through genetic
or biochemical testing that the person
does not have um normal biological
structures and then um also Beyond just
the interx issues it does say treatment
of any infection injury disease or
disorder that's been caused or
exacerbated by a trans transition
process whether it was legal or not um
can all be
treated so does that provide the
safeguards that you'd be worried about
if we were to look at the surgical
procedures I think so I'd like to hear
from my colleagues representative
Sho
um I'm not sure what we're being asked
right now um whether we're in agreement
to talk about something and of course
I'm always willing to talk about
anything but um I don't really have an
interest in including something about
about this in a final statute and I I'll
um you know in the Preamble to this bill
there's a lot of um studies say this and
studies say that
or um there are no long-term
longitudinal studies um or there are
longitudinal studies that say that
there's or or we have anecdotal stories
um and it's not that I'm above using
this kind of language you know um
evidence-based treatment science-based
treatment studies say this studies say
that um so I think the whole this whole
bill is skewed towards saying that we
have a major problem here and um I don't
think we do and
um and I I don't know the specific
answer although I just emailed to um the
person at Dartmouth Hitchcock um about
whether they' ever um whether they
ever um provide surgeries for people
under 18 um I'm I'm not sure of the
answer of that although I wouldn't be
um I I can't help I can't kind of
separate my feelings about working on
this bill from the context of seeing
um and I know you're trying very hard to
separate it from an attack on certain
people but I I'm having a hard time
separating it from an attack on um trans
people across the country and
um so I appre I really appreciate the
the introduction that you gave about all
the um all the ways in which um medical
institutions and Physicians have errored
um and have done real damage to people
have abused people um and I appreciate
that and I agreed with every one of
those
examples I don't feel like this falls
into the same category and so I am not
really I would not be in support of
something that limits
um surgical procedures you know unless
someone came here from Dartmouth
Hitchcock and said yes we willy-nilly
um operate on on you know 14year olds
you know after they've been here for 45
minutes we agree to do that um then I
would change my mind um but I that's not
what I heard when people came to testify
at all I heard that people
um anyway so to clarify are you saying
that you believe that um gender
reassignment surgical procedures should
be permitted to happen in New Hampshire
two
minors I would say that any of these
kinds of treatments were at my child
would be incredibly worrisome to me and
I'd be incredibly concerned not just
surgery but puberty blockers or um
hormone treatment um whether it was my
child as a minor or my child as an adult
I'd be incredibly concerned about the
medical consequences I'd be worried
about them um with all due respect I'd
love to hear your answer to her question
though the answer is
um the the answer
is I think that decision should be um
between a parent a child and the doctor
uh would you be willing to place into
statute that the parent unless their
parental rights have been removed um is
required to be a participant in the
decision around um gender
transition because you believe so
strongly that a parent should be part of
this discussion um that is actually
within the W path guidelines that the
parents should be involved in the
decision should be involved in the
process in the the therapy sessions not
necessarily the one-on-one therapy
sessions where the patient is speaking
with a appropriately trained provider
but also having family therapy
treatments where as a family they can
speak to the overall issues speak to the
benefits and risks and the the the the
clinical s sorry I I know as a doctor
you understand specifically what I'm
saying there but basically everything
that happens after you have an
intervention um so that there can be a
fully informed family decision as they
move forward with any any of the gender
transition
care or would you be willing to explore
whether there's appropriate language
that would honor that relationship so
that those those children can be in a
supportive environment with parents who
can work with them towards a lifelong
successful
life representative Canon
um I think I think I think there there's
another aspect about this that um I'm
struggling with um the number of
children that actually experience a
gender dysphoria in our state is
extremely small the population is
estimated for the entire transgender
community in New Hampshire is estimated
to be 610 of 1% and so the the number of
children that are impacted is
substantially less than that and so
we're getting to the point where we're
going to be defining things as stat in
statute for an incredibly small portion
of the
population this would be a targeted for
for the transgender community and then
it comes down to well there are other
medical procedures that are done to
children with other uh whether it's
diseases or other situations that are
defined by med that aren't in statute so
we're running into this thing where
we're going to be putting Medical Care
things into to statute that don't exist
for other procedures that may in impact
the similar number of children across
the state so I'm I'm running into uh are
we doing the right things by putting
things into statute that are going to
impact a very small portion of the
population representative kushman thank
you um so if I may uh we're talking
about
procedures and treatments that
can result in permanent sterilization
cardiovascular risk
osteoporosis um lifelong issues that
will require lifelong treatment to deal
with and we're talking about anywhere
between uh the research that I've looked
at 10 and 30% desistance rate um after
these treatments and and surgeries and
though it's a small number um of the
children and of the entire state of New
Hampshire we're talking about very very
serious um SQ ey and um a very kind of
new um a a new and explo exploding
rather fast um area of
medicine and as these guidelines are
formed I think it's appropriate um for
us to we're not you know whenever
there's a new technology or new
innovation many times there's discussion
about moratorium um you know to a wait
and see and you know we need to
understand what's actually happening and
as far as legislating Medical Practice
um when there is this much risk involved
and the fact that uh um a child may
regret it and have lifelong um SQL eye
Medical squel Eye as a result we're
talking serious trauma um I think that
it's a very appropriate place for the
state to step in we we require a
specific consent form for a woman to
receive to uh have a vaginal birth after
a
cesarian so I this isn't outside of the
Wheelhouse of what the the New Hampshire
legislature has done when it comes to
procedures that could um potentially be
um very
risky thank you a representative Moor
yes thank you um I just want to speak
back to something that representative
Shapiro said that
I've you know I when you talk about
things like this being and I've heard
this before an attack against a certain
Community I do think we have to be
careful about that because I don't
that's I don't that's not how I do my
life I don't go around attacking certain
groups of people this is specific to
minors so personally as an adult what
you do is your business live your life
the way you want to do it um I have many
friends in this community and they are
doing that but we are talking about
miners so that's the differentiation
between this being an attack on a
certain Community this broad Community
when many of us are just right now
wanting to just step up and say you know
what this is for the kids let let's let
them be kids for a little while longer
until they're adults and then can make
that decision so um thank you I'm
actually going to um refer to some of
what you brought up representative
Shapiro and then I'll recognize you
after um my motivation in pursuing this
isn't
to isn't to demonize any group or cause
any trouble for any groups um I as a
medical device analyst worked with many
emerging therapies um when we had drug
alluding stuns which are for um they're
actually not to prevent another heart
attack it opens up the blood vessels but
it makes it so you're not having that
chest pain that feels like heart attack
um they came out with drug eluding stems
so those had pet taxel or dosil taxel on
them and they started flaking off and
killing people so that was an adoption
where all of the clinical data all of
the clinical evidence showed that there
was going to be a benefit and it seemed
to be a minor risk it was broadly adapt
adopted and many many people died so
many that one pathologist had so many
patients through that she was able to
find the parts that had flaked off and
were found in people's brains
I as somebody who has involved in
medical technology and medical advances
for a large part of my career understand
that when we're in an early adoption
phase there's risks that are not known
and my motivation in actually coming
together and trying to figure out where
we can draw some good hard lines right
now is to protect children who may not
understand the way that medical new new
medical new medical findings end up
changing over time time and also may not
understand just how lasting an impact
those procedures can have um quite
frankly I think that if we can at least
set some minimum guard rails around this
like pre preventing this surgical gender
reassignment procedures in minors we're
going to have a lot less discussion on
this and so there will be less of this
conversation where people will
incorrectly feel attacked by people who
are doing this out of a motivation to
make sure that um BAS Bally that there's
a time to pause and think before you
undertake a procedure that has been done
nor been done predominantly in an adult
sexually mature population and that when
you translate a surgery that's been done
in an adult sexually mature population
to um children to minors who have been
undergoing did not go through normal
puberty and did not go through the
normal physiological processes of that
and have been on other endogenous drugs
that there are a risks that we will not
know until after these children grow up
and were able to see what happened um
right now you're looking to evidence in
adults and then extrapolating that to
children in any other field of medicine
children are not small
adults even adolescents even young
adults in some areas have an entirely
different treatment protocol than mature
adults so there are different guidelines
in some some specialty areas that are
under 16 and then 16 to 25 because
physiologically they are not the same as
an adult we know longer term data on
adults with these therapies we do not
know them with
children and to take the take the most
extreme part of this which is the gender
reassignment surgeries and minors off of
the table I think that there'll be a lot
less of this discussion of this and
it'll bring a little bit more peace a
little bit more understanding and we can
start talking about how we're trying to
trying to make sure that they aren't
early adopter that are harmed so
representative
Shapiro thank you
um I would apologize for
extrapolating um my view of the national
situation um extrapolating that to this
the people in this room and I apologize
for attributing motives to um the people
in this room thank you um to go back to
the earlier question about parental
consent
for gender affirming care in general or
um you know I've learned a long time ago
to that Hippa and consent are so
complicated that every time you think
you have it right you you don't have it
right but my sense um as some someone
who's been in you know in related
um a minor getting gender affirming care
or any other care who was going to have
a a medical procedure a surgical
procedure would need um parental
consent um meaning to be included in
decision-making and consent to actually
belief is that that is already being
done at the at the one place in New
Hampshire where this kind of care is
offered if I if I was to find out that
it was a problem that it wasn't um
happening then I would be open to the
idea of
having including that in Statute in some
way I think it's already covered but if
if I found out it wasn't covered um I
would agree that because I feel
like 14 year olds 17 year olds shouldn't
be having these kinds of surgeries
without the agreement of their physician
the the medical team their family um
being included in making that decision
together um thank you representative
kushman thank you madam chair um so on
on all of this discussion um the what
keeps popping back into my mind is there
are currently guidelines and um so we
have some guidelines of the most forward
um and most well researching um
organizations it's a global organization
that they've set forth and it includes
the consent piece it includes um the
surgery piece it includes you know
hormones and um you know uh kind of
eliminating extraneous variables um like
depression and trying carefully with
children with
um autism spectrum disorder um so we
have the guidelines and this is a new
and expanding rapidly expanding area of
medicine and um we're wanting to put
these guard rails in
place so it I would say that it's more
appropriate to put the guidelines in
place and then or at least propose them
and and then if there's something in the
specific guidelines that we propose that
does interfere with current practice by
these organizations then they can then
um or or by you know any of the clinics
and and they don't agree with it then
they will have the opportunity to show
us exactly where and why and that will
help us in sorting out the fine details
of those
guidelines thank you um and uh one of I
have another statement then I'll toss it
back over to you representative Shapiro
um you had also mentioned when you were
speaking about the opportunity to be
involved when those earlier decisions
happen as well and in those guidelines
it does say that for hormonal treatment
um it's important to have parental
involvement too um the
question it sounds that representative
Shapiro that you are believe that at the
point of surgery the parent needs to be
part of that consent process
um how much earlier and with what kind
of side effects do you think that the
parent should be involved in the consent
process um when one of the known risks
may be um lifelong fertility issues
incre increased cardiac events um and
then especially increased depression
because some of these therapies
especially some of the hormonal
therapies have increased depression and
if a parent is in the dark they may not
understand that their child is now
because of their medication um more
likely to undergo a significant
depressive event um that could have life
ending consequences when do you think
that the parent needs should be part of
informed when my niece who's 38 now um
was a young child um she was incredibly
so the the the doctors suggested a
puberty blocker so she would have time
to be a more normal
height um you know she didn't have a
genetic problem that seemed to be
causing her to be short she was just
she's still really short um so she was
put on a puberty blocker um for I I
don't I I have no memory of how long it
was to see if she would grow a little
bit more she did grow a little bit more
but not very much and um and her parents
would you know there's no way that that
would have been done without her parents
involvement and consent really probably
they made the decision I'm sure they
consulted with her but um so I would
think
that any kind
of any kind of medical um care other
than the ones that are already kind of
separated for um privacy reasons like
like um STDs and um substance use
substance misuse care um where it's been
judged a long time ago that it would be
better to allow people to access this
with in privacy um any other care I
think should involve parental
consent and parental involvement thank
you we may have found a point of
agreement and if we can find agreement
out of this I think we're going to have
a huge win um um because you brought up
the the precocious puberty I think that
that's actually an important part I have
some information to share with us on
that can um so yes representative I just
want to make one other comment that it's
um I would I was wondering if
representative kushman was suggesting
that we um embed these um protocols or
these um guidelines into statute and um
would wonder if if if we ever thought
about doing that what would be the
repercussions of every time they change
their guidelines you have to change the
law or How would how we would even do
that that's a separate issue um so uh we
can take up that separate issue in a
moment so um treatment of central
precocious puberty which is when you're
going through puberty early usually is
done for height reasons um because if
you develop puberty too soon then you
stop um developing with height and so it
is um the central PR proser puberty um
it occurs in one to in 5,000 to 10,000
children mostly among girls and U mostly
on girls it's idiopathic they don't know
why it happened so normally when that's
done it can be initiated as young as six
and then it can be initiated it's almost
always initiated before Tanner stage two
um and then it is ended they don't
really know exactly when to end it um
but there's not really any data that
shows that going past the bone age of 12
or 13 shows any benefit so um for the
most part it appears that clinical
practice ends um ends the the hormone
the the puberty blocking drugs before
the time that many children are going
through Tanner stage 2 which is when um
puberty blocking drugs are indicated for
um for gender related issues um which
actually really brings into question how
relying on the long-term safety and the
long-term consequences of puberty
blockers in central picosas puberty
relates to the use of uh puberty
blockers in gender issues so that's just
yet one another area where we're trying
to do the best we can with the science
we have but we need to make sure that
it's not oversold to these families
because this is hard for us and many of
us have medical backgrounds can you
imagine a parent when it just suddenly
suddenly there's a there's something
that's a
surprise you'd have to find someone a
lot smarter than me to respond to that
distinction um so if we can go back to
this idea of embedding some of the
guidelines in I think that if we can
perhaps find a floor of what should be
needs to be practiced in New Hampshire
um that we could look to some of those
guidelines we have many places where the
statutes do ref refer to guidelines or
to um different protocols um in
administrative roles we have even more
of those and those chip typically are
updated every 10 years um there are a
few places where in law or in statute we
refer to Port sort of an evergreen um
Evergreen link to guidelines and
protocols um but that is very rare
especially because you don't know which
direction it's going to take and there
may be a need to change it before then
um in some of our building codes we
purposefully hold back on a new addition
of the building codes because the ch are
more beneficial to other regions than
they are to New Hampshire so the idea of
referring to a specific area makes sense
uh looking at the guidelines it's more
of an informational guideline where
there's the principles within the
standard of care 8 from wpath and they
basically have it where you would where
where if as a lawmaker were to implement
it some of it needs to be tuned to your
area because some places are using icd1
some aren't but having those principles
about which medical providers are able
to provide care um actually I think
would be very beneficial for everybody
because uh W paath requires that they
have specific training and specific um
ongoing training in gender issues and in
diagnoses of other mental uh in sorry in
in diagnoses of mental illnesses which
may have an impact or may present
similarly so that those can be ruled out
so that you make sure that you are
actually treating true gender gender
dysphoria gender diversity as opposed to
mistreating um and illness or
mistreating something that um that
actually needs to be treated in a
different way so um I if we're willing
to look at these we can take a few
minutes and I can I can pull together
some of the language that we could pull
directly from the from W paath
guidelines in order to set some
requirements around that um do do we
think that there should be a level at
which somebody needs to be trained in
order to provide medical care for um
transgender or gender questioning or
individuals representative
notam yes but I have
no idea of what I mean who would be our
guiding person to do you know what
medical
Association or whatever would decide
what level of expertise what kind of
training would that that's a very
difficult
question you know so if there if there
was a clear-cut set of definitions that
um we could look to an outside agency
perhaps representative
Canon I think that might be an
appropriate question to ask um uh
someone from Dartmouth um is how do they
they judge that somebody's at a level
that they can provide services I do know
in my own speaking to audiences about
how to that the things that they should
be looking for the feedback was well we
don't feel qualified to provide that
service so in some ways they're self-
policing themselves saying I I'm not
going to take a patient because I don't
know how to care for them uh and and so
that's a good thing and and but then
there are others that have established
practices that Fe that um for for some
reason whether it's a an organization
are are deemed that they have the
knowledge and the ability to provide
that service
um
okay so that might be a question for our
friends at Dartmouth okay I think that
that might be a great question to find
out from them if we could have them here
um in a follow-up meeting so would we be
willing to look and so with that we'll
we'll take a look and try and see if we
can get some basic language that we can
ask them about um to be able to present
and say this is what we have from these
guidelines make sure that it's available
ahead of time and if there's a different
competing organization that is more
suited to determine who can provide
medical care and Medical Counseling that
um that that would be the next steps um
part of the concern is were there any
more comments on that
representative um I think I think
hearing from people who are um
intimately involved in this kind of care
would be a good way to go about that
but are
there are there any other similar
um guidelines in statute about like what
specific care beyond what specific
certifications or what specific
experience or training that medical
providers have to have beyond the fact
that they are uh
thoracic surgeon say to do a certain
kind of surgery are there other examples
of this in statute is my question there
are many examples in statute um of
different professionals who need to have
certain certifications in order to
practice in a certain area I believe
that that is also the case in medical
professionals that's why we have so many
different areas and different SE
sections of lure um but I know for a
fact that in in other areas where where
we're not talking about uh the Integrity
of a person's body um we absolutely do
have those those specific certifications
in many other
fields that that
are that are separate from the parts of
Statute that list the scope of
practice I mean are there certain are
there certain
like
diagnostic groupings that are then
like there's not being very articulate
are there certain
diagnoses that are referred to in
statute
and who can provide care for those
diagnoses in terms of their training
their experience their
certifications um if you look at that
that's part of why we have a breakdown
of some of the different Medical
Specialties the question is how granular
and in an area of
emerging an increased emerging area of
therapy uh making sure that only those
people who are qualified to provide Good
Health Care would be beneficial to this
to especially a community that feels
that the world is against them to make
sure that only those healthcare
providers that truly do know the best
science would be I think one of the most
beneficial things that we could
do um perhaps you could refer me to like
a spe specific example involving some
other kind of care that this would be
parallel to I I'll see if there's
anything that's parallel to that
I quick question yeah just a quick
question so as of right
now Dartmouth is what I've been hearing
they they
are most likely not performing
transition surgeries on
minors as far as we know
right so my question is regarding
why why we why why why aren't other
providers doing
this are are they allowed or are they
not allowed like do we have a statute in
place right now that prohibits them so
then why aren't they doing
it it's sort of managed within the
medical field within the um it's it's
like there are only certain centers in
the in the country that have transgender
Health units Dartmouth is one right um
down in Mass General and uh a number I I
know so those those have staff that are
trained right specifically for
transgender health so it sounds like
Dartmouth
does and are so yeah I really like to
know if this is happening there then i'
like to know that sooner than later
represent perel probably doesn't shed
very much light on the situation but I
just got an email from um Courtney
Tanner who's the one of the legislative
Lia zones for Dartmouth hitchcook and
her I to our surgical procedures related
to transition done at Dartmouth
Hitchcock on miners even if infrequently
and she wrote as a rule no like any
exceptions so okay that actually seems
even a little bit more concerning to me
do because um the one of the biggest
areas is there's a lot of areas where
you're not able to practice certain
surgeries unless you have a certain
volume um and even within different sub
different subgroups of patients but I'm
glad we have that information that gets
us a lot closer and um then for more
followup from Dartmouth I would like to
know what those exceptions are because
um we we want to make sure that nobody
is denied appropriate care but we also
want to make sure that people are
protected um and especially
children um representative
kushman than thank you madam chair um
it's my understanding so from that same
um
website I was talking about earlier um
there's also a list of surger surgeons
and one two of
them um do surgeries at Dartmouth
Hitchcock but there's a third that does
them at Elliot um and then as far as
hormones um Planned Parenthood of
Manchester there's an MD in Portsmith
the lovering health center in Greenland
affirm Endocrinology in Lebanon amus
health in Manchester Goodwin Community
Health in summers worth in equality
Health Center and
conquered as well as the UNH Health and
Wellness Center um they also you know
they're also offering these um services
so uh we invite them to give us feedback
on on whatever it is that we put forward
as uh the Baseline guidelines um for
this or I would like to U Madam chair
and
um I'm just considering you know if if
they are not doing these surgeries on
minors then there should be no push back
of having that in statute and if there
does become a pressing need and the
evidence comes to show that it is much
beneficial contrary to what the evidence
is showing now we can bring that back
for they could bring a bill to change
that later just going back to the
concern about putting guidelines in stat
you um thank you that's uh very helpful
to know who is providing uh surgical
procedures in New Hampshire
um that so that list
was two hospitals surgical procedures
and all the other one were hormonal
hormonal yeah I just wanted to make that
clear because somebody listening in
might think oh all of those places are
doing surgery they're not thank you for
that
clarification um so the safeguards for
the um gender affirming medical and
surgical treatments according to wath
are that the healthc care professional
is assessing transgender and gender
diverse um adults for physical treatment
shall be licensed by their statutory
body and hold at minimum a master's
degree or equivalent training in a field
relevant to this role and granted by a
nationally accredited statutory
institution uh able to identify
coexisting mental health or other
psychosocial concerns and distinguish
these from gender dysphoria in
congruence and diversity
um able to assess capacity to consent
for treatment have experience or be
qualified to assess clinical aspects of
gender disphoria gender in congruence
and gender diversity undergo Continuing
Education and healthc Care related to
gender dysphoria gender in congruence
and gender diversity and healthc Care
Professionals assessing transgender and
gender diverse adults seeking gender
affirming treatment shall consult with
professionals from different different
disciplines within the field of
transgender health for consultation and
referral is needed um I I think that one
of the biggest areas that we do need to
perhaps exercise some caution is that
some of what we're hearing from the
schools it sounds like they're actually
conducting medicine without a license
with some of the counseling that is
happening from teachers and others
within because we are hearing statements
by some people who are on school boards
that basically say that they that the
people in the schools are those who are
best prepared to speak with children
around around sexuality and transgender
issues and having those discussions
especially within this whole context
about being able to identify um I
basically identify all the issues around
it
that by giving free reign to have
discussions about these topics in school
and especially one-on-one discussions um
that this is actually quite possible
that somebody
may may be providing false information
misleading information or D ous
information when what they should be
doing is referring any of these uh
students with concerns to an appropriate
health professional who has the
appropriate
training so is that this is one of the
areas where I think the fact that we
have some reference to the schools is
quite
important so um we actually um we have a
representative prudo O'Brien actually
has some information about um about some
some of the statements that some school
board members um have made about the
appropriateness um about whether
children should be speaking to their
parents or should be speaking to people
in the schools um with their questions
around gender issues um I'm not sure if
you want us to speak a little bit more
amongst ourselves or if this is
something that um you either wanted to
send me the information so I can read
the statement that was made or if you'd
like to share with
us
yes because I I'm very worried about the
potential practice of medicine within
the schools um when that really should
be happening with appropriately trained
medical
providers and well okay when when you do
have that then uh we'll need you to put
the light on so um sorry if I was uh if
I shifted gears a little bit quickly on
all of us there it just seemed very
relevant to the issue of healthc Care
Professionals being appropriately
trained um is there any push back on the
idea of making sure that people are
speaking to
competent
providers I didn't hear the question oh
just I I I I'm going to assume that
nobody has a problem with making sure
that people are speaking to competent
medical um providers when they have
questions
so just lost it I thank you for having
me I'm representative prud Brien from
Derry I wanted to be certain that I was
very accurate in what I say um a few
weeks
ago someone sent this to me um because
they were worried about it
and I read about that uh this school
board member thinks that there should be
experts from outside of the community to
come in and speak to students about
gender issues be
because because they think it is not
acceptable for any parent to impose
their religious beliefs or in personal
ignorance and dictate the education of
um I think that this is a personal issue
that parents do have the right to speak
to their children about um then the per
the Schoolboard member goes on to talk
about generational differences and
that's an that's that's an age issue so
if parents are
older than I don't know 40 or something
uh that doesn't change the fact that
they care about their children and they
have the right to talk to their children
about their deeply held beliefs I think
that if parents can talk to their
children about religion this is just as
personal and important to parents
and I think that's um thank you that's
what I have to add that's really helpful
so um in the reading it sounded like um
that they were saying that the parents
should not be involved in their in these
these discussions with their children
but to leave it to the schools and that
parents of the older Generations are not
equipped to do so so I I don't think
that is accurate I think parents know
their children parents love their
children uh the overwhelming majority of
parents love their children very much
and want what is best for their children
and oh is there a question I mean does
anybody thank you
I just wanted to clarify so someone on
the school board thought that parents
should not talk to their children about
specific
subjects but they need they need help
because of their ignorance and religious
beliefs and things like that I think we
have to worry where our society's going
if we're beginning to dictate through
laws what parents can talk to their
children about don't you yeah I think
that parents are equipped and and and
even if even if parents aren't so
equipped they're the parents I I agree
with you completely yes and when parents
do find an issue with their children
that is new to them they become equipped
I mean as a parent I mean anything when
when I became a parent the first thing I
did was learned all about breastfeeding
for example that thing thank you I think
we've actually may have found a point of
agreement the fact that we need to make
sure that parents are not cut out of
these
discussions is that something we can all
agree on I I'm 73 and I think think I
should have the right to talk to my kids
about although I have to be very careful
to tell you the truth sometimes around
certain issues but good I think parents
should always Bravo I mean parents
should always be encouraged to engage
their children about all
issues thank you representative kushman
thank you and and then in that vein and
you know coming from that same
um testimony that you've
provided a parent has you know more
stake in discussing these things with
their kids than a teacher who's not
trained on this so that's where the rub
is I think to insinuate that a teacher
who has no formal training on this and
is not a medical professional has more
of an ability and a and a right to
discuss these complex medical issues um
with a child and a parent so it it
really speaks to both requiring the
competency and ensuring the parent
involvement thank you very much I agree
with that
and my feeling on that is the same as
yours but even further I think
that even teachers I I applaud teachers
and the work that they do um but even
the the best ones are mere visitors for
a short period of time in our children's
lives uh the parents are there for the
Long Haul the parents have been there
for the Long Haul they have watched
their children over a long period of
time and they will be there when the
children have problems in the
future and uh that's the difference
that's a big difference I I I myself got
a lot of help from from some wonderful
teachers when I was growing up and
social workers and I love them I think
of them as you know the very heroic
figures in my in my life
but sometimes I would stop and think
when I was when I was a teenager about
them that they were paid to be there
they were they were paid to be there
that was that was a little different
that was just a different perspective
than parents have thank you this is been
very very helpful I really appreciate
you bringing this so that we can
understand um some of those perspectives
from outside representative Canon thank
you uh thank you thank you for your your
comments greatly appreciated um I had
both of my daughters struggled in school
with uh
um depression and
anxiety and um it was brought to our
attention by the school that we might
want to seek out a therapeutic care for
someone to investigate why and um just
just like in all procedures is what what
went on with the therapist that we
finally got um it was like like Las
Vegas whatever went on there stayed
there but the kids went back for
multiple sessions and they were fine and
you knew and you had the ability to help
your children because you were informed
that's very important to a point some of
some of what was discussed in those
things was between the child and the
therapist not with us directly but you
were able to address it like a
responsible parent because you had the
information that's I think we get to
that lat and think we if we can equip
our schools with the knowledge that if a
teacher encounters a child that that
experiencing a gender dysphoric type
situation is that they it's it's above
their pay grade so they should be
referring it to somebody else who can
help thank
you that's I maybe maybe we can get
something really good out of this thank
you representative missor similar
testimony just happened at our school
board meeting recently where um a PA
professional and she spoke as a PA
professional at a Manchester Charter
School she' not she did not come
speaking as a private citizen which she
later said she did but she didn't it's
on video she spoke as a par professional
in a Manchester charter school and she
sat right at a table like that and said
I am
this and I work at a charter school in
Manchester and we are teaching gender
identity and sexuality information to
kindergarteners it is being done that
was her exact same words and then
wondered the next day why her school
wasn't under investigation because when
parents hear about this stuff it's
rightfully so you're going to be
concerned like wait a minute I didn't
know that was happening but then you
know then came up to the table a few
weeks later and was appalled at that her
schools now under investigation for that
on a private Schoolboard video so that's
why it is so important now that parents
are involved and we have an RSA in place
that makes it legally requires schools
to give parents notification two weeks
before anything like this is either put
on a whiteboard or taught in schools or
anything like parents have to be
involved that's all we're saying you
know is to keep parents in it to that
point point the Department of Education
recently put out a a memorandum on that
specific issue it's on the depart the
New Hampshire Department of Education
website uh Frank edelblute wrote a me a
memo regarding that to inform parents
that had questions about that wanted
more information so I want to mention
that for anyone watching yeah thank you
yeah thank you thank you that was very
helpful thanks for bringing that insight
to us um I'm seeing that we have a
little bit less agreement around the
preventing um surgical transition
procedures for minors than I was hoping
we would have but I think that may be
something that we should try and work
forward with in a future um meeting to
try and get more information from
Dartmouth and from any other providers
so we can understand what's happening um
I think we all have um is was it a
correct read that we all have an
understanding that um the teachers and
others within the school that are not
appropriately trained shouldn't be
counseling students on this but instead
should refer them to an appropriately
professional representatively on can I
just like point of clarity are are we
sure that we're like can we
maybe Reas the question maybe
of you know are are we all in agreement
that transition surgery for minors under
18 is should not be a thing um yeah let
me get let me get through this other
question around the um around teachers
and the discussion um there's there's
definitely an importance to make sure
that anybody who's discussing this is
well trained aware of the recent
evidence and is keeping up with with all
the advancements in this Dynamic field
um do we have agreement that teachers
and other school professionals um should
not be counseling students on these
issues but rather making an a referral
and notifying the parent unless there is
a reason um under existing statutes to
exclude the parent from that
notification through any of the DCF type
processes representative Shapiro yes um
I'm not I I'm not sure that I'm not
clear what
we I mean I know we're just making an
agreement to talk about it but I'm not
clear about exactly what we're making an
agreement to talk about like counseling
or curriculum or talking about gender at
all I think this is a slippery slope um
and I think we have to understand
the the so the question I was asking
complication the complications um
so so for example you know my
granddaughter has two mothers right so
um
some people might feel it's
damaging to um in the course of talking
to an elementary school class to refer
to families that have two same-sex
parents I I I don't begrudge them that
they would feel very offended that their
child is being exposed to that well it
would be damaging to my grandchild to
not be exposed to that in school so I
think um I'm not sure if we're talking
about clinical treatment when we're
talking about like that the school
shouldn't be doing clinical treatment or
what they should be talking about in the
course of um you know developing
curriculum or just general conversation
in the school but I
think in some states there have been
very um rigorous and I think harmful um
laws passed about what can be talked
about in school and what cannot be
talked about in school and so I would
certainly not be in favor of being on
that
um so involved in that I had asked the
question about counseling so when
somebody comes and says that I'm not
sure about my gender that that then
would become counseling if you're
discussing intimate topics like that
there's a there's there's it would be a
separate discussion about the sexuality
and discussion of that in classroom type
um situations but right now I'm talking
about when a student comes and says I'm
not not comfortable I'm not comfortable
with who I am I think that I'm somebody
else is a teacher equipped to provide
the counseling that would then be
required and is that rise to the level
of having a appropriately trained
Medical Professional representative
Canon
um I would agree with you that needs to
be a referral to someone that knows what
they're talking about um my concern
would be if there's a referral
it are we outing a child by referring
them
for uh gender help or or or can we or is
there a way for a a recommendation to
seek therapeutic help and let the the
therapist decide if they need to refer
them to another specialist
um because the the challenges in in
outing a child is where damage could
occur
um especially if a parent is is doesn't
want to hear
it and I'm thank you that's uh
definitely one point I have also do have
a Counterpoint though that there is the
concern that when a child is undergoing
something that is this big and this
complex if their parent doesn't
understand that there's something going
on not even giving the opportunity for a
supported discussion to happen with the
parent the the child may be so so
concerned about this that they're not
able to confide in a parent who would be
supportive and even a parent who may be
hesitant won't know to look for the
signs of a potential imminent
catastrophy and that harm and keeping
the parent out of the look out of the
loop could have also have severe
consequences representative Canon just a
continuation using the example of my
daughters I have no idea why they went
in to talk to a professional for their
anxiety situation and they still at this
point when they're 40 and 30 6 years old
still won't discuss those discussions um
that went on with the therapist uh so we
we as parents never knew and still don't
know uh what what was uh the problem the
good news is they resolved
it uh and it didn't require our
assistance uh which may not be the case
it's in a transgender
child's uh situation however for a
school
or someone in the in the school to come
to a parent and say we need we think
that your child needs to see someone
who's who's uh knowledgeable about
gender dorer and and those things could
potentially be a problem for a child
who's already struggling themselves and
and as as we've seen is where a child
will take their own life because they
now don't feel uh they're getting uh the
home representative naram I I I think
the point that you're trying to make is
that teachers who are not trained in
counseling should not be counseling
correct and I would agree with that just
there's lots of well-meaning people that
have had some personal experiences
themselves that they think well I can
help them but you're right it's it's
above their pay grade and as um Jerry
said referral so and you know I'm sure
um get getting close to kids and then
realizing well child will tell them
something and they need to refer them to
school guidance counselor or or law
enforcement or you know whatever it is
because they're mandated reporters and
anyway yeah representative kushman yeah
I I have to agree with you that and and
to your concern um it I think as long as
you know it's a referral for counseling
they don't they should include the
parent but if there's some concern at
least it's a professional who's talking
to the child about it um and they might
not name the issue they just might say
you know we want to refer your child for
counseling because they're H showing
some anxiety issues or or you know
something and um it's beyond our scope
of you know Authority and and knowledge
right
okay I think we may actually have some
areas where we have some agreement um I
know that I need to use um the
facilities I don't know if we can uh
just uh take 15 minutes or do we want to
take 15 minutes or do we want to take
back it's
12:30 I have no food I'm not going to
make my wanted flock whatever
so okay whatever so we'll just take 15
minutes for the restroom maybe if we
wanted to just consolidate some thoughts
amongst our separate groups and just
consolidate some thoughts and figure out
our next steps yeah okay thank you so
we'll take a recess for 15 minutes until
well thank you everybody and welcome
back to the work session on House Bill
619 um as far as the guidelines and all
the other information um there are
guidelines on the w paath website it's
the S so8 um I can email that to
everybody on the subcommittee and
there's also the endocrine Society
guidelines um since they've been dealing
with hormones and those treatments for a
long time I think that that would be
helpful for us also to review there are
some other societies as well if anybody
wants to share it but I I figure um I'd
be happy to look at any as we work on
our work going forward um I I I'm really
happy and really impressed with all the
areas where we found agreement today I
think that it shows how much we're all
looking to try and work together and try
and find the right Solutions and get
past this whole top level controversy um
and actually look at the the best
well-being of of these children um so I
actually I'm going to see if
representative kushman can sort of
summarize where we are um and uh and
figure that out from
there sure thank you madam chair um so
we had some agreement on um in on
setting some guidelines for um the
actual medical care um pulling from the
national organizations who have done the
most forward research on this um we also
came to some agreement about um ensuring
that there's parental participation as
much as possible um and we've
discussed um redefining conversion
therapy and we've also discussed um
agreement on establishing that um the
appropriate medical professionals are
providing counseling on this um to
minors and not those who are not
trained um I believe that's everything
and as next steps and just uh with that
yes I think that is everything and I do
want to clarify on the conversion
therapy it's going would be going to
language that is more clear about not
coercing anybody so that we can make
sure that the language doesn't cause
fear and confusion and a resistance to
therapy because right now I think
there's a lot of confusion about how
that's interpreted so we would not be
looking to change the intent or change
the purpose of the conversion therapy
ban it would be simply to clarify it so
that we don't have people who are
worried and that that is causing
controversy and making this hit the news
media because it's not good for anybody
to have this fight continuing to play
out in the news media so next steps um
so as far as next steps um I I see us uh
bringing a draft forward and then having
that available for all the entities in
New Hampshire that it may impact and
giving them an opportunity if their
practice deviates from the best practice
guidelines um that we would like to also
put in statute that they bring us um
their policies and procedures and and
tell us where exactly it deviates and
what the evidence for that is and what
their outcomes have
been um and um that will give us an
opportunity if there are myths we can
dispel them here in the committee that
will help reduce that high level
controversy um that we're seeing in our
communities right now um that you know
some of these more egregious things that
may be happening in other countries or
in other states that are not happening
here let's get that on record and if
they're not happening here then we can
we you know the guidelines will be in
place and make sure they won't happen
here in the future um so that's what I
see as our next
steps do those uh General conceptual as
work for our next steps or are there
concerns on
those and we we can summarize that and
put that in writing so that we can uh
know our next steps and have that
written in an email um we aren't going
to have discussion um outside of the
subcommittee um but if there were any uh
any errors in what I do send out to
everybody as those next steps let me
know and then I can fix those if that's
based off of this conversation that's
just a correction representative Shapiro
so just to clarify the next step would
be to have another session of this
committee and to invite some people who
are involved in providing care um to
participate in that yes we would
specifically be looking for testimony
from those who provide care or whose
organizations provide care with specific
feedback um on language that we can then
provide to them as we draft different
sections of this um so that they can
know what what we're going to be
discussing at that point and anybody
who's interested in any of that language
or any of that information can email me
and I can send that out um my
information is on the St State House web
web page um just so that we can make
sure that we do this as a committee um
we already heard about the overall
topics and we don't need to have um
another overall hearing situ uh
situation because we already know um all
of the people who are brave enough to
come and speak in front in public about
the general topics what we need to do
now always talk about what we can do so
that we can stop having to have those
big larger larger conversations that may
not be as productive um just as a as a
as a whole society and work on focusing
on those areas of agreement to make sure
that we understand where care is in New
Hampshire um what guidelines if any we
put into our statutes to make sure that
to make sure that everybody on both
sides feels comfortable about where the
state of of uh transgender and gender
diversity care is in New
Hampshire representative Shapiro so I
would just like to clarify for myself
that um these four areas Medical Care
guidelines parent involvement
appropriate
medical
um having appropriate training to
provide certain um certain types of
treatment um I think we were talking
about counseling mostly
um re redefining using different
um I I think for just for I just want to
speak for myself that for example in in
terms of Parental
involvement no in terms of in terms of
the example that we were talking about
um before we left that um if a child
um brings up some distress about their
gender or questions their gender um that
you know the teacher shouldn't like take
that on as their own counseling project
that there should be a process in
schools for referral and um to a trained
professional a competent
professional sometimes they're different
I'm trained incompetent um so I'm in
complete agreement with that but I just
want to be clear that that doesn't mean
I'm in I'm in agreement with with that I
think that this should be in statute and
that that we should proceed to to find
wording to um amend this bill about that
um so there's agreement about the basic
concept but I don't agree that this is
something that we should be taking up in
this committee or as a
legislature um thank you for that
opinion if we can get to where at least
you agree on what the words would be if
they were to be in law at least then we
can um we can get to that point about
whether or not it deserves to be in law
very will to talk about it but I just
want to be clear what I'm what I'm
agreeing to that that makes sense and
thanks for helping us set our
expectations so that uh that nobody's
opinions are misconstrued um just just a
quick comment on that having been on a
school board and dealing with school
policies um the the
challenge challenge for us we can put
something in statute but the school
system May take that and do what they
feel like in in addition to um so that
that that's a problem area just in
general no matter what we say here in
the legislature to put on the school is
that policies can be written locally
that get implemented locally and and
that's that's always been a problem a
challenge because even the N the New
Hampshire School Board Association only
provides a draft for schools to use and
then they change it based on their local
needs thank you that's a that's great
input from a former School Board member
so thank you very much uh representative
missor yeah thank you I I agree be and
it is often times too that you know and
I've watched it because I've been to a
lot of school board meetings lately is
because there's nothing in place it just
like there's this big limbo land that
they're in and it actually causes more
division when there's nothing to fall
back on that says hey
we need to they need to do this and
that's it because when it's just a kind
of a free-for-all which I've been again
to a lot of meetings lately and it's
been a challenge of of them not even
knowing what is in place and what's not
regarding things so I think the better
that we can do about putting something
just to for them to look at and refer to
would be really
helpful thank you um I think that these
are great next steps I know that we all
have complex schedules so I will um in
query everybody offline so that we can I
can again assemble my spreadsheet and
see where we can uh where we can fit our
meeting where that will all be available
I appreciate you all taking the time and
really being willing to dig into
this what what is the deadline for us
to vote to recommend something to the
our committee um we would need to vote
to recommend something prior to when we
meet an executive session to vote on the
bills all of the bills need to be dealt
with um by the 17th of November which is
effectively the 16th um I think the
sooner that we're able to address this I
think the better um but we do still have
a a bit a couple weeks within here and I
think our chairman was um was it only
yesterday was it the day before I think
it was Tuesday so days I've been here um
was going to maybe try and schedule our
executive session for November six um
there was some discussion about either
the 6th or the 13th um would give us a
little more
we constraints that we okay and with
that it would be helpful to know sort of
your general constraints through
probably the the 13th or 14th so that I
can then also help the chairman know
when we'll be able to slot in our
executive session for all of our work so
um that that would be very helpful so
fantastic and thank you very much I
appreciate all of you and I appreciate
uh I appreciate the opportunity to
actually get into the into the depth and
and and importance of the
you
that